okay welcome to the split game the fifth
game against morgue and morose mr. smoke
and burrows it's a big previa as you see
okay okay yeah it's um seems to be very
simple stuffy everything is played
instantly I took three seconds for ten
moves that's it's really really quick
and he's not lost yet that's a good good
accomplishment so again let's clarify
things a little bit and then play with
f5 G cakes echo f5 with the rook okay I
don't know let's go i 5 i'm just playing
it a bit Sybilla bit simple here check
it's probably an equal shot equal
disposition Nyjah fire for that might be
might be awkward okay if it checks me
now I see yes that's a bit that's a bit
awkward so I go to G 895 i can go Bishop
g5 let's no no problem I think ok so
let's see if I can put something on
deform knight on d4
to be ready to play the five the right
moment and I completely forgot that this
is possible stupid mmm what a stupid
move b6 just h6 yeah and it's not ever
going them these are the kind of
situations that really give away games
nothing going on really hm
now that's just awkward position is
awkward after he takes that bishop only
six my light squares
hmm maybe it's not that bad but totally
completely unnecessary
yeah maybe it's still still kind of okay
don't see anything particularly great
yeah this is a bit awkward to meet with
that Queen Queen a aid checking idea
dad looks bad really looks bad check
check
notify I have to go to e6 which is just
not great
yeah if he repeats not not much that I
can do I really really have to take that
repetition now after allowing 95 he's
not clicking that button okay now he
seems to try something what is the idea
and not sure let's just cover this for
for the moment and go from there maybe I
actually played night III that that
would have been far more interesting
actually
okay night that cannot be that bad for
me really okay check so hmm really
threatening much I mean e5 hangs but I
can also just go back let's see how can
I untangle King and King g6 maybe for
bishop who remove the bishop away nights
are notoriously tricky that is
definitely true time morning it's not a
good idea
and of course I didn't see that very
very bad
I don't that cannot too much him and 95
is coming amazing I than Jack the night
is just so much better I am in in those
in those that kind of positions with the
bloody folks check just cost you so much
time not running into the folks check I
don't give it them may be here I don't
know check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check white forfeits on time ahh
yes whoo yeah it's better to be lucky
than good yeah there wasn't that was his
that was his what are you doing there
hey yeah come on I'm opening up and no
one allowed as a sport it's probably
probably wiser otherwise I never get
anywhere there okay so let's have a look
close Sicilian and it was not much
happening actually a lot takes takes
okay five it's a bit simplistic just
okay we can do that i just wanted to
play some bubbles yeah and now he
actually had Bishop takes you five well
that's cute that means i have to do
something else here Bishop a2s suggest
by the engine okay Wow ship c5 it would
have been something and now I went there
there are p6 what about this can I not
start without that that probably is also
not so clear because these success is
bad hmm yeah that means that this isn't
such a great position here probably it
was a bad idea to just take on a form
that that simple way of playing I mean I
can always keep the tension and probably
that was better one point is that well
he he cannot really take that that looks
wrong I had would have been better it
was just yeah there was a bit mindless
so the way it went I was averse quite
clearly worse but check check around
here i have from some still in some
trouble yeah night night III was better
already tinks ya hear yeah it's amazing
the computer still gives equal the night
only for is just very strong and in a
practical game I think why does even
easier to play in a blitz game in
particular i blundered that the night is
just so awkward yes multiple ways to win
now check but yeah he gave me that porn
for no particular reason check and he
had 96 wins the bishop but he played
this GT I'm winning air so it was a
blunder fast after
oh wow okay well thanks for watching